[Music]
the most damaging bias that can come up
in poker and I also think very often in
life is what's known as confirmation
bias so that's basically when you look
for you have like a pre-existing want to
believe something a desire that for
something to be true and you will over
value evidence that confirms that belief
and dis FAL you evidence the disproves
it and in poker that can be absolutely
devastating if say you're in a big hand
and a ton of your chips are in the
middle and your opponent's made a big
bet and you really owe your hands not
that strong and you really really want
to believe that they're bluffing so that
you can win this hand and you'll then
look for all the signs yo I saw that
they hadn't looked shaky in that way and
they seemed a little uncertain look for
all the evidence that could suggest that
they are bluffing and then not really
ask yourself that you know those vital
questions like okay well what evidence
is there that they actually have a
strong hand and learning that skill is
absolutely crucial to be a great poker
player and I think that applies to too
many parts you know so if you're trying
to make a big business decision and you
know should I hire this new person ISM
as a manager and you say you know
they're they're an old family friend and
you really really like them so you
really do want to hire them you'll tend
to look for all the signs that they
could be great but dismiss the perhaps
overwhelming signs that or sorry they're
very strong signs that they're actually
not the right person for the job
so it's it's very important to just
remember that your break our brains are
naturally inclined to to look to confirm
what we really want to believe the
status quo bias is basically when we say
to assert whenever we catch ourselves
saying well it's always been done this
way or it's worked for me like this in
the past and this is my way of doing
things that's the status quo bias
murmuring is it's rather ugly head and
what this means is that where we have a
tendency to
not want to change our methodology
perhaps you know change the process with
which we do something because it's it's
perhaps worked sometime in the past or
we like doing it that way and in poker I
remember I used to catch myself falling
into that I had like a style of play
that had worked for me a number of times
and I would over rely on that and and
not update my my playing style based
upon the table that I was at because
perhaps I didn't enjoy it as much or I
found it more scary for example and and
the same thing can apply to us in in
life the important thing there is to
just be aware of the bias and look for
situations where you could be using it
to justify staying in a situation that
you're a little bit scared to change
another classic one that comes up in
poker is the sunk cost fallacy where
again you'll have a lot of chips perhaps
almost all of your stack is in the
middle and yet you are 85 to 90 percent
confident that you have the worst hand
and you're not gonna be able to get
you're putting another chip in the pot
is probably not a good idea but will
often go to ourselves oh well I put I've
gone this far I've put this much in I
might as well see it through to the end
but if you have very strong information
that actually from this point onwards
putting more money in the pot is a bad
idea then you shouldn't but we have this
this this belief that why I've put this
much time in or this much effort that we
should catch we should continue on in in
poker when whenever a new card comes out
even though historically you've put in a
lot of money into the pot when that new
information comes out that's it's an
entirely new situation what's happened
before in terms of how much money you've
put in is actually largely irrelevant
and the same thing applies to if you're
investing in a business be it time or
money when no matter how much you've put
in over the last few years that say if
new information comes out that this
market is shrinking
some legislation has been passed that's
gonna make it even harder to proceed
then you have to largely ignore the the
decisions that you made yesterday or
before you go that information you're in
an entirely new situation and you have
to evaluate it with all the information
that you now have available yeah it's
interesting to observe sort of the
difference in emotion you can have when
you end up in a very similar situation
so for example I I had a hundred
thousand chips I'm in a big tournament I
have a hundred thousand ships and I lose
a big hand and I go down to fifty
thousand and then if I compare it to I'm
in the same tournament and I had twenty
five thousand chips I double up my stack
and end up with fifty thousand so these
are two different situations I have the
same number of chips but I feel
completely different between the two and
that those then those differing mindsets
you know if in the time I've just
doubled up I'm feeling great I'm like
wow I've I'm up to here now let's see
where we can go whereas I've hard my
stack I'm feeling despondent I was like
man I had this many before and so often
you'll end up playing badly from this
point and playing great from this point
and yet it's stupid because actually
practically you both you're in exactly
the same situation in both so poker
teaches you to detach yourself from how
you got there and just going okay this
is my situation right now what's the
best best procedure moving forward
[Music]